y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
un corto estar con ustedes me encuentro
aquí porque bueno la verdad es que no sé
por qué pero quisieron que viniera a
contarles cosas de mi vida
supongo que estoy bastante particular
porque porque soy elegante o porque
quieren saber de mi vida nada más pero
sucede que
mi nombre es
aedes agypti sí estoy un poquito a
poquito hembra
fillón como suena mi nombre es es lindo
no es parece notorio y hasta musical
aedes aegipty a mí me encanta
[Música]
bueno aquí estamos y se estuvieron
viendo los que alejandro
quiero contarles que estoy recontra
feliz muy pero muy feliz porque cada día
tengo más fama me encanta disfrutar de
la fama y los lugares más cálidos del
mundo
sí pero también en aquellos lugares
donde no es tan cálido todo el año pero
tuve unos meses bastante calurosos y
este viernes me encantan las casas
casa carta de todo tipo casas chicas
casas grandes casas de ricos casas de
pobres casas con mucho jardín con poco
jardín con patio sin patio casas
en las casas miren ustedes quiere decir
que las tomaban sus casas bueno en sus
casas
yo encuentro todo todo lo que necesito
para vivir
por ejemplo con los iguales entre pares
de plantas
entre cortinas la cara encontró varias
para descansar encontró lugares para
refugiarme del frío del viento de la
vida
y ésta tiene encuentro en la planta
juegos o separados que son mi alimento
y encuentro muy pero muy especial que
era infaltable o sea para mí es
importante encuentro al amor
es bastante romántica
en esos encuentros amorosos salvo pecar
personas
somático el peso cuando te como personas
les sacó sangre y la sangre me sirve
para obtener proteínas
para hacer los vómitos mis huevitos
cuando necesito un lugar para colocarlos
y me pongo más a ver si encuentro algún
recipiente con agua que haya dejado
olvidado que el caso llegó vía o que
regaron y no se lo olvidaron un bebedero
que quedó con el agua y también ahí
mismos
y somos nación larga son muy chiquitos
miren la foto
de la larva van creciendo como los
chicos crecen y luego de eso pasa me han
estado que se llama y de la
van a pasar a la etapa de la adultez
como yo
y para ser adultos adultos con alas
bueno claro adultos con alas o sea
mosquitos con armas es como ustedes
generalmente nos conocen
y esto es mucho y yo
simplemente entonces ustedes
probablemente escucharon sobre la
metamorfosis de las mariposas de los
gusanos de seda o sí seguro
y
cuando la casa entró entre las plantas
entre las paredes techos lo que voy
buscando son lugares como éste miren las
fotos
me encantan estos lugares variando y
poniendo huevos en cada lado por ejemplo
los bebederos de animales que son las
mascotas de ustedes algún que otro tacho
o valdo olvidado algún barrio o tonel no
se comprende como lo llamen que pueda
preguntar o que ustedes quieren que
junte agua propósito neumáticos los
neumáticos me encantan y alguna que otra
pileta botellas cuando quedan para
arriba así con la boquita para arriba
las puertas macetas y no pueden faltar
los floreros con agua fotos enraizando
mucha gente cree que yo me pongo vivimos
en estos lugares de las fotos que están
ahí
charcos pantanos lagunas zanjas pero yo
no puedo ponerle esos huevos a esos no
son mis criaderos
no lo sé decir que yo incluso un vídeo
que hay gente que quiere ahí matarme y
están fumigando y fumigando y yo me río
un poco porque yo ahí no estoy donde
estoy estoy en sus casas que ustedes me
albergan tan amablemente
y
en este momento que yo creo que hay una
conexión con los todos que creo que
siento esa cosa calidad creo que
llegamos a que comparte mi felicidad
bueno en este momento quiero agradecerle
de corazón
esto que ustedes me alojo en sus casas
que menos hospedaje como acogedor y
particularmente gratis
es como vivir en un oro incluso toda la
vida me envían un poco me parece hay
algunos que de estar envidiando puede
jugar por su hogar claro son sus casas
pero son mi casa sí gracias por esa la
verdad que
gracias pero algunos se ríen pero otros
ponen una cara como de lo que quieran
pero sí
paranoia
tan seguro que me sorprende
lo que están diciendo como que me duele
yo creo que tenemos una amistad
entrañable y
bueno
también si ustedes no quieren que yo
esté en sus casas
lo que tienen que hacer es cuidarlas
principalmente no dejar cosas con agua
objetos que puedan acumular agua revisar
después de una lluvia
bueno
esto es decisión de ustedes ustedes y yo
no me voy porque quiero ustedes me están
están negando bueno yo pensaba
no
este mosquito
bueno solo son mosquitos mi nombre es
nora ahora burroni y yo trabajo en la
universidad de buenos aires y en conocer
el consejo nacional de investigaciones
científicas y técnicas y lo que hago es
estudiar a los mosquitos de distintos
aspectos ecológicos desde hace muchos
años y desde hace muchos años acá en la
provincia de entre ríos
y algo que
quería contarles es algunos algunas
pequeños pequeña información que les
puede ser de mucha utilidad y que creo
que son importantes para toda la
comunidad los mosquitos además de picar
los molestarnos y causarnos alergia de
distinto grado también pueden
transmitirnos ciertas enfermedades
por ejemplo el dengue el cica
chikungunya fiebre amarilla en zonas
urbanas estas enfermedades son muy pero
muy importantes a lo largo de todo el
planeta porque afectan a millones de
personas cada año un mosquito de aes
egipto que está sano pica a una persona
que está infectada ese mosquito queda
infectado y luego días después puede
picar una persona sana y de esa forma
infectar la así se producen las
epidemias
y algunos de ustedes pueden hacer que
esté pensando por qué no solucionamos
este tema tan complicado con la
fumigación porque nos fumigamos y de ese
modo eliminamos y eliminamos los
mosquitos y los mosquitos no tenemos el
problema pero hay un problema cuando
aplicamos fumigación química aérea lo
que estamos matando son los mosquitos
que tienen alas pero no las larvas y las
pupas que se encuentran en los criaderos
claramente después de unos días las
larvas y pupas van a ser mosquitos
adultos o sea se recupera la población
y además hay una cosa importante con los
productos químicos para mosquitos los
mosquitos pueden crear resistencia
entonces al crear resistencia si uno
utiliza un insecticida químico muy
fresco forma muy frecuente lo que
termina pasando es que cada vez mata
menos mosquitos
entonces no logramos tener el control y
además el día que lo necesitemos por
ejemplo en una epidemia lo que sucede es
que no es eficaz entonces
es otra contra que tiene este tipo de
fumigación la otra es que mata a todos
los insectos porque es insecticida tal
vez los insectos de mayor tamaño no pero
los afecta y en los insectos hay grupos
que son beneficiosos para nosotros por
ejemplo las abejas y otros son
totalmente inocuos sin contar que ellos
son alimento también para otros pequeños
animales como reptiles en atracción o
pequeños pájaros es decir que esto es
una herramienta que hay que utilizarla
con mucho cuidado y es muy útil en un
momento crítico sí pero como preventivo
no
y la otra pregunta que tal vez alguno de
ustedes puede estar pensando es porque
no se ocupa el gobierno de este problema
y listo lo que yo me planteo con esto no
es que el estado o el gobierno no tenga
su papel lo tiene y es muy importante y
es muy variado pero mi pregunta es por
qué pretendemos que excluir nos del
control cuando esto está sucediendo como
las con paul mosquito antes en nuestras
casas con nuestros objetos y con
nuestras actividades cotidianas es algo
tan personal es tan tan nuestro que es
bastante difícil pensar qué
no hacerse cargo de este problema
ahora les voy a contar rápidamente
algunas experiencias que tuve a lo largo
de estos años que me pueden haber
ocurrido a mí pero les puede ocurrir a
ustedes y espero que les sirva como para
transmitirlas o que les ayuda a
controlar el criaderos en sus casas por
ejemplo tengo una tía que le gusta regar
sus plantas con agua de lluvia y junta
el agua de lluvia en baldes como éste en
realidad es ese y lo que hicimos bueno
era a cada rato era un criadero de
mosquitos esto entonces lo que hicimos
es de forma muy sencilla una tapa con
alambre y con tela mosquitero y aunque
parezca una pavada hace varios años unos
cuantos más de cinco que esto no es
criadero de mosquitos y ella sigue
regando sus plantas con agua de lluvia
una cosa del mes pasó hace un par de
años y me sorprendió es que ya había
pasado el verano era justo en la época
de pi de la última epidemia la del 2016
había pasó al verano y ha pasado el
otoño llegarán días fríos yo tenga
calefaccionada la casa y abro la puerta
del placar para sacar un suéter y
aparece un mosquito volando voy lo
capturó bueno saben soy biólogo un
poquito obsesiva fui lo captura era el
de seis gente y en una hembra
y esto que tiene de anecdótico lo
anecdótico es que nosotros les
proporcionamos
el ambiente fíjense que no siendo siendo
invierno estaba calefaccionado y yo le
estaba proporcionando el lugar para que
él pudiera vivir
mi madre a este mensaje y hace mucho
avanza y tiene muchos bonsáis y antes lo
que hacía era colocar a cada bonsai un
bajo maceta un porta maceta entonces
teníamos en pocos metros cuadrados en su
casa muchos criaderos no todos eran
criadores pero muchos entonces hablando
explicando recordándole lo que hicimos
fue que tener cada vez menos criaderos y
hoy en día no tenemos criaderos allí no
hay bajo macetas las plantas se siguen
vivas igual y el otro otro punto ellos
son adultos mayores esto es como para
recordar que tenemos amigos siempre
conocidos o parientes que pueden tener
dificultad para cuidar su jardín o su
patio y entonces seamos solidarios con
esa gente para poder realizar esta tarea
y una cosa que yo les llamo el misterio
del bótox con agua no puedo decir que es
una tradición es algo que ha crecido en
las últimas décadas lo cierto es que se
ven en viviendas pero se ven también en
ambientes públicos en ambientes privados
y algo más crítico se pueden ver en
escuelas en hospitales centros de salud
cementerios entonces es el problema es
que estos criaderos este tipo de
criaderos debería dejar de existir y me
pongo yo como ejemplo
porque yo antes de empezar a trabajar a
estudiar sobre mosquitos yo también
ponía fotos en agua porque me parecían
decorativos atractivos bueno tomé una
idea que es la de colocarles arena bueno
en el momento que trasplante parecía que
no iban a vivir pero miren hoy están
preciosas y están lo que más lindas que
antes se riega la arena sin inundar y
les quiero trasladarte a saludar por
último a tres preguntas de cortas que me
dan siempre vuelta en la cabeza y
quisiera trasladárselas para ver qué les
parece a ustedes una es por qué es tan
difícil que podamos modificar estas
pequeñas actividades o pequeñas cosas en
nuestras casas para que no haya
criaderos de este mosquito que nos pasa
que nos ocurre podemos preguntarnos a
cada uno de nosotros otra vez
[Música]
porque es la idea de que alguien venga a
cuidar nuestras casas a nadie se le
ocurriría a eso bueno vengan todas las
semana alguien entra venga y mensah que
todos los posibles criaderos no somos
nosotros son nuestros objetos
esta idea de creer que el estado tiene
que realizar esa tarea parece un poco
complicada y ahora les contesto no voy a
mi parecer no que el estado tiene su
función pero nosotros tendríamos que
realizar esa tarea de cuidado de
criaderos y la otra que me llama un poco
la atención es que la gente cuando habla
del medioambiente o cuidado del medio
ambiente cuando es algo precioso o
cuando estaba del otro lado del
continente de otra gente el otro del
otro lado de el hemisferio
nos parece maravilloso y el y nos
ponemos una camiseta defendiendo al
medio ambiente pero no nos damos cuenta
que el medio ambiente más cercano que
tenemos son nuestros hogares entonces si
son nuestros hogares también debemos
cuidarlos y también debemos pensar que
eso es parte de cuidar el medio ambiente
y lo último es que se me ocurre que
además de conocer que me sucede cada vez
que hago encuestas o hablo con gente
conocen muchas de las cosas que les
contó el mosquito antes pero falta un
poco más falta la acción
entonces los invito a actuar en sus
propias casas para que no haya criaderos
si no hay criaderos lo que no va a haber
está el mosquito adulto y si no este
mosquito adulto no va a ver las
enfermedades
entonces
sin que escuche filo menos
no les dimos la gran vida al mosquito en
nuestros hogares
[Aplausos]